voici comment devenir totalement
invisible sur WhatsApp et que aucun de
vos contacts sache que vous êtes
connecté sur iOS mais également sur
Android là regardez je suis connecté sur
mon WhatsApp et on voit sur le deuxième
téléphone qui collectait juste en face
loulou oui c'est moi loulou on voit que
je suis en ligne et lorsque je me
déconnecte il vous montre la dernière
heure à laquelle j'étais connecté
regardez hop je suis en ligne je suis en
ligne sur ligne je suis en ligne je peux
vous faire ça pendant des heures alors
sur iOS c'est facile vous venez ici dans
réglage vous allez ensuite dans compte
et dans compte vous allez dans
confidentialité vous allez sur présence
en ligne sur la première qui peut voir
ma dernière présence en ligne vous
mettez personne et la deuxième la plus
importante pour être complètement
invisible sur WhatsApp qui peut voir
quand je suis en ligne vous allez sur
identique à la présence en ligne la
premier si vous voyez je suis pas
connecté et je reclique sur tout le
monde je redeviens en ligne sur Android
vous avez les trois petits points en
haut vous cliquez sur Paramètres dans
Paramètres vous allez sur
confidentialité présence en ligne et là
vous cochez personne et puis identique à
dernière présence en ligne est-ce que
cette astuce vous êtes utile dites le
moi dans les commentaires et si ça vous
a rendu service pensez à vous abonner